good afternoon
welcome to
yale university and our
symposium observing the 20th anniversary
of the
genocide against the tutsi in rwanda
my name is david simon i am the
the
acting director of the genocide studies
program which along with the council on
african studies
and the shell center for the study of
international human rights
is one of the three sponsors co-sponsors
of this program
the program is uh has been uh several
months in the making uh but was born of
a recognition that
the
first of all the rwandan genocide is
something the genocide against the
tutsis is something that has uh
influenced us all touched us all and
influenced us all it's something that
almost everybody here speaking at a
university where the youngest students
are younger than 20 years old i now have
to make an exception but almost
everybody here was alive when the
genocide happened
and almost everyone here who was alive
when the genocide happened
especially americans i don't think
really had the chance to process it at
the time
yet over the last 20 years
the
the genocide people have begun to
recognize the the meaning the importance
of of the genocide the fact that it
happened and what it says about us
us as americans us as rwandans
us as
members of the global community and so
the other reason why
we thought it was particularly important
to have an observation
of some sort of this 20th anniversary
was that
it seems like an appropriate time to
to reflect upon the ways in which
the global experience of having a
genocide as well as the rwandan
experience
the way that has has changed us the
changes the legacies of that genocide
and so the way the the afternoon is
organized
is that our first panel which i'll
introduce in just in a moment will
address the international legacies of
the genocide the way that the genocide
has influenced changed international
relations
uh then at three o'clock we will there
will be a coffee available and the
the common room on the second floor
get a chance to stretch your legs a
little bit
re-caffeinate
and we will reconvene at 3 30 where i'd
like to focus more on the the personal
element the personal side the personal
journey and the national journey that
that rwanda has taken
um i'd like to thank you all for taking
time out of your day to
uh to sit at this uh to come to this
event and to sit down and and confront
uh something that a genocide a a sort of
scar on on humanity that
ordinarily i suppose it's pretty easy
not to address and
i i think that that being here
uh and having the chance to listen to
our esteemed uh guests uh is a is it's
both a moment of reflection
and a moment of of
construction
for us all
we've
started just a touch late so i won't
dither on anymore and rather i will
introduce our first panel
by introducing uh
jim silk who is the director of the of
the shell center uh which is based over
at the uh at the law school at yale law
school
uh jim
has uh
has we've worked together with genocide
studies in the council of african
studies on a number of events and it's
uh it's a delight to have jim uh
participating uh in this panel uh
without any further ado i'll let jim
introduce the guests
uh hello everybody and welcome it's sort
of our tradition at the law school to
give very short introductions but i
think i will give a little bit longer
introductions because i think it's
important for everyone to have a sense
of
why the panel that we have here is such
an appropriate panel to be talking about
the
sort of international legacy of
the the the genocide in rwanda so i'm
going to go
from nearest to me to furthest and i'm
going to begin with
edward luck
who served
as the united nations first special
advisor
on the responsibility to protect he was
at the level of assistant secretary
general and served in that capacity from
2008
to 2012.
he was responsible for the conceptual
political operational and institutional
development of this principle
and was the architect of the secretary
general's
three pillar
strategy for implementing the
responsibility to protect
as well as the the prime author of the
first four reports on on r2p
between 2009 and 2012 and clearly the
responsibility protect was one of the
the the concepts and the developments
that i think david and i had in mind
when we thought about a
continuing legacy
of
the events in rwanda
dr luck has published many books
particularly on the un's security
council on compliance with international
law
on u.s exceptionalism on arms control
and on the ending of of war i will
mention just a couple of the books one
is called on the endings of war another
is called arms control the multilateral
alternative
mixed messages american politics and
international organizations
he has taught at columbia at princeton
at cionus poe
he's headed research centers at columbia
and at the woodrow wilson school in
nyu school of law
he served as president and ceo of the un
association of the united states
and is a senior vice president of the
international peace
institute
he is also a
graduate
of dartmouth college where ba in
international relations and has his m.a
and phd in political science from
columbia and a master's in international
affairs i guess that's what that stands
for from colombia's school of
international and public affairs
to
his left from the direction you're
facing
is james traub
he writes a weekly column terms of
engagement for foreignpolicy.com
he's been a staff writer for the new
york times magazine and
previously for the new yorker
he's written extensively about
international affairs
but also about national politics
urban affairs with a number of books in
particular about urban affairs and about
new york and about education
he's written as they said in the new
york times magazine the new yorker but
in many other publications as well
recently he is reported from
afghanistan iraq pakistan egypt iran
sudan guinea-bissau
congo sierra leone angola georgia kosovo
and haiti reads kind of like a list of
the places in which human rights
organizations are required to focus
their work
his most recent book is the freedom
agenda why america must spread
democracy parent parentheses just not
the way george bush did
he published before that the best
intentions kofi annan in the un
in the area era of american world power
he's currently writing a biography of
john quincy adams
he teaches american foreign policy at
the nyu
university of abu dhabi
as a senior fellow of the global center
for the responsibility to protect
a fellow of the
center on international cooperation and
a member of the council on
foreign relations
and at the end
zach kaufman zachary kaufman zac to me
but
um which i will start by mentioning that
connection zach is a graduate of yale
college and and also of yale law school
and most recently has
been a lecturer
in the department of political science
at yale he's been a visiting fellow with
our shell center for international human
rights
yale's genocide studies program
and the
information society project at yale as
well
he is a term member of the council on
foreign relations
before
his this period of being a fellow at
both harvard and yale he was an
associate at the law firm of omalvani
and myers
but also was
in washington and was also an adjunct
professor at
george washington university's elliott
school of international affairs
earlier he worked on the investigation
and prosecution of
suspected atrocity perpetrators
in positions at both the department of
state and the department of justice as
well as at the international criminal
tribunals for rwanda and for the former
yugoslavia and at the international
criminal court
he's the founder and president and chair
of the board
of the american friends of the kigali
public library rwanda's first
public library and i know devoted an
enormous amount of time to
promoting the establishment of the
kigali public library
he's the chair of the advisory
board of indigo africa
which is a social enterprise based in
rwanda and is on the boards of genocide
watch humanity in action and the u.s
holocaust memorial museum
he has published two books already uh he
is the editor of social entrepreneurship
in the age of atrocities and
social entrepreneurship has been a real
focus of zack's work
and he's also the co-editor with dr phil
clark of and i'm looking at the more
full title because it's relevant here
after genocide transitional justice
post-conflict reconstruction and
reconciliation in rwanda
and beyond
um
in addition to his
uh degrees from yale college and yale
law school he has his phd in
international relations from oxford
where he was a martial scholar
and
for all of them i have pages and pages
of publications of articles and
and
and speaking and
all of it hovering around
the issues that we're talking about
today so we're very fortunate to have
all of you here and i think the plan is
for each of
our panelists to come up and speak for a
while and then we will
entertain questions i might try to get a
little conversation started first then
we'll open it up to all of you so
good luck